if you want to hear how a character from
unbreakable split and glass also appears
in the village then stick around to the
end of this video
welcome to things you missed today I'll
be covering one of my favorite movies of
all time the village if you haven't seen
it I recommend you watch it first
because you definitely don't want to
spoil this one for yourself this thing
is such a masterpiece and in the
broadest sense it's a story about the
dangers of sheltering oneself the
village elders were each scarred by the
horrible things that happened in the
outside world so they created the
isolated village in the Covington woods
to keep themselves safe from the
heartbreak that they endured in modern
society but after some time their
sheltering of themselves kept leading
them back to that same heartbreak they
were blind to the fact that their new
society was becoming the very reason for
their suffering and it would ironically
take someone who is literally blind to
help them see the solution so in today's
episode I'm also going to be giving the
gift of sight so that you can see a few
things you missed the opening scene is
the perfect example of how backwards the
state of affairs and the village has
become the entire community mourns the
death of a young boy the son of one of
the village elders we later find out
that the reason for his death is because
the village lacks any kind of medicine
and the elders have sworn an oath never
to leave the confines of the village a
clue about the secret held by the elders
can be found very close to the beginning
of the movie sorry we'll find you nobody
is allowed to step foot beyond the
barrier they enforce this rule through
the use of legends the legends of the
monsters in the woods surrounding the
village draw inspiration from the idea
of legends in real life all throughout
history parents have made up and passed
down stories to get their children to
behave in this case those we do not
speak of from the village are very
similar to the monsters that ancient
cartographers used to discourage sailors
from exploring unknown areas of the Seas
but even see a similar kind of warning
painted on the rock at the edge of the
village some of the legends are based on
real things the idea of the creatures in
the woods was spawned by actual rumors
in the area they did exist rumors of
creatures in these woods it is in one of
the history books I used to teach in the
towns and the practice of marking doors
with red paint is pulled from the
religious story of Passover where the
Israelites homes were marked with lambs
blood and thus were passed over by the
plague of death of the firstborn there
are other psychological tactics employed
to keep people in the village
the use of fear they've gone to great
lengths to cover the village in the
color yellow which they call the
protective fella they rid the village of
any Reds because the settlement is
placed in the center of a large
outgrowth of red berries by conditioning
the young to associate the color red
with the monsters they create a sense of
danger for anyone who leaves the village
that's why Ivy is a perfect hero ivy is
blind and therefore will not be scared
by the color red there is a running
theme in director M night Shyamalan
movies where those who are impaired are
stronger in some unforeseen way we see
it in Elijah and Kevin from the east
rail trilogy that has family and signs
and Nana and pop-pop from the visit
there's also a strong link between the
village and Shama lands 2013 film after
earth in the village Lucius theorizes
that the creatures can sense emotion and
fear an IV later believes that she can
pass through the woods safely because
she has no fear and after earth there
these monsters called IRS's who like ivy
are blind but are able to detect
pheromones that the human body dispels
when experiencing fear but perhaps the
story that most closely ties in with the
village is the story from unbreakable
splits and glass each has three main
characters in the village we have Noah
who's mentally ill but physically strong
ivy who is physically impaired by her
blindness but mentally strong and
lucious who is physically strong and
mentally strong the characters in the
east rail trilogy filled the same roles
kevin is mentally ill but physically
strong Elijah is physically broken but
mentally a genius and David down is
mentally and physically strong Lucius
and David Dunn even share the same trait
of being the strong silent type both
characters rarely open up their mouths
there's one more link that possibly puts
these movies in literally the same
universe one signature of M night
Shyamalan is that he almost always makes
a cameo appearance in his movies an
unbreakable split glass he plays one
character named Jay an IT guy
responsible for setting up security
cameras who appears in all three phones
in the village he cameos as the guy
reading the newspaper at the security
huts where his name is also J the J
worst image latter maybe this means that
all four films take place in the same
universe together or that he just likes
the name Jay I mean we'll probably never
know for sure one thing we do know that
M night loves is Philadelphia
eleven of his 13 films take place there
and if you pay close attention the
village is one of them mr. Walker
mentions that he once taught history at
the University of Pennsylvania which is
located in Philly and the newspapers
seen when ivy leaves the woods to
retrieve supplies is the Philadelphia
Journal but they'd seen on the newspaper
is also the same as the movies release
date July 30th 2004 and if you look at
the articles in this newspaper there
all tragic headlines which ties in with
the idea of the elders wanting to escape
the horrors of the real world and start
their own society in the woods one of
the reasons that Ivy's father is
comfortable with sending her is that
she's visually blind and she won't be
able to convey the secrets of the real
world when she returns even the escorts
that set out with her are instructed not
to venture past the road so that she
would be the only one to go over the
wall and into the outside world the wall
that she climbs over is covered in vines
of ivy like all great walls are and her
name is literally Ivy Walker she's the
only one to go over the wall
it is also fitting that she be the one
to go because the wildlife preserved
that they're secretly living on was
owned by her grandfather before his
death ivy is blind but she's able to
sense a certain color that people give
off that only her and her father can
sense and when lucious was stabbed by
Noah she was no longer able to sense his
color because he was dying they cannot
see his color you could say that one
major theme of the movie is that it is
the things that we don't see that are
the most significant the villagers don't
see what really lies beyond their
community the elders don't see what they
have become is the very thing that they
ran from and Ivy does not see when she's
holding the color red which is used to
scare people away from ever trying to
leave the woods this theme is also
reflected in the cinematography we end
up looking away for many of the most
significant events from ivy lucious's
first kiss
- no his attack on Lucius - the
appearance of Noah in the woods dressed
as the monster to try to kill Heidi
where our view is obstructed and were
forced to rely on her other senses to
track the monster now if he really had
balls he would have just made the whole
movie black or maybe that's overkill or
maybe it's a good podcast idea click the
video on the left for the entire 144
things you missed in Shem wands Easter L
177 trilogy and if you love or then
remember to subscribe to see ZZZ world
from new Horrors every week wring that
death battle for notifications and I
will see you in the next one assuming we
both survived
[Music]